quand on a été dès sa genèse 23 24 ans à
ce moment 24 ans au contact quotidien de
la mort eh bien on a compris on a
compris vraiment avec sa chère avec ses
viscères que la vie est une chose
merveilleuse et qu'elle reste jusqu'au
bout ainsi parlait maurice genevoix
secrétaire perpétuel de l'académie
française certes mais surtout et pour
toujours
l'écrivain dans le témoignage d'abord
censuré et publiée en un recueil ceux de
14 aura rendu au plus près ce que fut
véritablement la condition des soldats
de la grande guerre
il est venu à l'écriture par la guerre à
cause de la guerre parce que
effectivement on lui en a fait un petit
peu le devoir et on lui a dit paul dupuy
secrétaire général de l'école normale
supérieure qui s'est attaché à maurice
genevoix par les lettres que je ne vois
lui attacher du front lui a dit je ne
vois vous êtes revenu vous en avez le
talent vous devez écrire et c'est comme
ça qu'il devient écrivain
les genevois devient écrivain en
demeurant là où il a grandi à
châteauneuf-sur-loire petite ville en
amont d'orléans où il apprend à lire et
écrire dans une école qui s'appelle
l'asile châteauneuf sur loire où ses
parents tenaient boutique la boutique
que tenait sparrow qui a été pour lui
une formidable un formidable creuset
d'imagination d'invention et je crois
véritablement la source de son intérêt
pour le mouvement pour le travail des
artisans pour la vie finalement des gens
modestes et là beaucoup écrit il a parlé
des odeurs des bruits des manipulations
du mouvement des allers retours des
communes et ça a véritablement bercé son
enfance et au bout de la rue coule une
rivière la rivière la loire centrale
dans l'oeuvre de l'écrivain comme dans
sa vie elle même
quand on lit d'ailleurs je ne vois dans
toute son oeuvre est notamment dampremy
des roches la loire est une figure
féminine maternelle et pourquoi parce
que à l'âge de 12 ans lorsqu'il apprend
la mort de sa mère son père ne s'occupe
peut-être pas beaucoup de lui attristé
trop patrice rey pour s'occuper de cet
enfant et c'est auprès de la loire qu'il
se réconforte et qui le trouve
effectivement la force de dépasser ce
deuil d'enfant ce drame non
cinquante six ouvrages ciselé d'une
écriture à la fois sobre et poétique ont
pour la plupart le val de loire et la
sologne pour cadres dont raboliot qui
lui valu le goncourt en 1925 ancré dans
sa région et donc écrivain régionaliste
aubry genevois il a toujours récusé
cette étiquette parce que je crois que
c'est une étiquette qui est
incroyablement réductrice en fait
régionaliste ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire c'est l'étiquette que place
éventuellement le parisien sur ce qui
n'est pas de paris mais régionaliste non
naturaliste peut être éventuellement
beaucoup plus mais c'est surtout avant
de rentrer dans une étiquette une
personnalité qui était curieuse de tout
amoureuse de tout de la nature et aussi
de l'harmonie entre l'homme et la nature
et donc son oeuvre
elle n'est pas régionaliste elle a pour
cadre souvent effectivement le val de
loire et la sologne
mais elle parle de choses qui dépassent
largement la simple région c'est
l'histoire de l'homme et de la nature
l'harmonie entre les deux après la
disparition de l'écrivain c'est d'abord
sa fille sylvie genevoix qui assure la
conservation de son oeuvre littéraire sa
correspondance ses dessins et aquarelles
puis après son décès bernard maris ce le
compagnon de sylvie en prend la
succession avant son assassinat lors du
massacre de charlie hebdo d'un an mme
harris avait naturellement en transmet à
son tour cette responsabilité au petit
fils de l'écrivain julien l'arrière
genevois
c'est lui qui aujourd'hui a confié le
temps d'une exposition ce fonds maurice
genevoix au musée de la marine de
châteauneuf sur loire en contrebas du
musée la grève de sable est encore là où
se promener comme souvent maurice
genevoix lorsqu'il a pris la signature
de l'armistice le 11 novembre 1918
[Musique]